all right well summertime is here
finally and for Wall Street's best and
brightest that means fun Sun and also
some book Bloomberg's Julie verhage
asked some heavy hitters what books
around their summer reading list and she
joins us now with a look at some of
their must reads this full list covers a
range of genres from history just
studying startups let's start with Bill
Ackman Bill Ackman had a lot of stuff on
startups and entrepreneurship not
necessarily surprising because you know
starting a big hedge fund is kind of
like you know entrepreneurial and
whatnot it is the first one was 0 to 1
which was written by well known Peter
Thiel which is definitely I haven't read
it but I want to read it sounds like a
good book next one was bold which is how
to just make a big impact on the world
create wealth also sounds like a great
book that's right we've had him on on
Bloomberg Television quite frequently
and I know you know he does you know he
talks about big ideas he actually talked
a lot about Elon Musk in you know in
many respects ok Sallie Krawcheck yeah
her list I was so excited to get her on
here cuz it was so hard to find a woman
to get here too and I was like Sally is
the perfect one to add her list one of
them she hasn't read yet cuz it hasn't
even been released it sorry I
anticipated next book by Harper Lee go
set a watchman and the next one was when
Paris went dark by Ronald Rose bottom
which I hadn't heard of but i did a
little you know research on it it sounds
like an interesting book to Whitney
Tilson's list includes one of our
colleagues yes yes Ashley Vance's new
book on elon musk which sounds
absolutely very interesting Elon Musk is
obviously you know very very well known
person in a very interesting person to
uh right and also the poorly made in
China book all right then okay let's
also just quickly Lloyd blank fine his
his books yes the CEO of Goldman Sachs
he majored in industry at Harvard so
it's not necessarily surprising that he
picked the largest book which is the
discoverers it's a very historical book
takes a really deep dive into human
history dead weight the last crossing of
the Lusitania and the Wright brothers by
David McCullough yeah uh stop light
reading no not necessarily although
Steve Schwartzman who we didn't mention
but is on the full list online
mentioned outliers by Malcolm Gladwell a
little bit more light rating than these